[Music]
bleep you
[Music]
pilot to Bombardier
we are sending you on a mission pilot to
Bombardier pilot to Bombardier
you are being summoned for mission
[Music]
just note pilot to Bombardier
if you accept this mission we're going
deep into the murky waters of the
[ __ ] underworld and maybe end up in
the bottom of the [ __ ] Bermuda
Triangle but it doesn't matter cuz a
mission is a [ __ ] mission
[Music]
oh [ __ ] it's Friday [ __ ] uncle
Joey here direct from [ __ ] Studio
City wishing you a beautiful happy
[ __ ] April first remember I'm the
first rule [ __ ] equal war [ __ ] broke
we got a star from scratch
we got a claw ourselves out of the
[ __ ] working grave a [ __ ] broke
this plate that's why I'm here [ __ ]
lookin sharp today just own the McGill's
already I've been making moves on
morning calling this [ __ ] tellin
this [ __ ] to suck my dick write
down my goals right now my ideas my
dreams that's it
it's a beautiful [ __ ] day to be alive
you're alive but no [ __ ] you sad about
it's Friday I don't give a [ __ ] there's
gotta be a way to pick up an envelope
collect
I did not invent it understand the [ __ ]
is wrong with you try to hear a young
man you're sitting in
you should be out scratching your head
getting your balls with but now you want
to sit there [ __ ] wallow and [ __ ] I
can't who gives a [ __ ] I couldn't either
I couldn't neither but who gives a [ __ ]
it's Friday on Fridays you can
understand me he's gonna get the right
hands briefly to open up the [ __ ]
kaput see you out there swing big and
make a few dollars maybe read a book
magazine have a coffee there's heavy
just be you whatever whatever [ __ ] that
happened to just being you know [ __ ]
hands no mysterious look make him
believe
so I smelled the river keeps me honest
is any public money lurking around me
hanging out lying on mobile I'm here for
you [ __ ] smoking reefer jet jet
jet Joey was with the chitchat spot that
slopes I'm trying I'm trying you know
little kids don't try this at home this
is a local Joey [ __ ] strength briefing
here good show as bad and bread my [ __ ]
wasn't tight not as tight as it will be
tonight and Saturday night out of 7:30
at 9:45 tonight 7:15 9:30 tomorrow night
I got my man Jack I said Louie I'll have
Mexican half Armenian we've better than
have understand I got my man Johnny Rock
with some [ __ ] up glasses on him Tommy
Easter came down here last night I'll
rip that [ __ ]
apart with Joey what's with the chitter
chatter crack that [ __ ] open if
I'm trying to hit people
you know give me a breather let me vent
a little bit is it okay if I [ __ ] come
at the time
is some good [ __ ] smokey smoke
right here this is Mickey Mouse og from
sunset or the same places you got to go
and get the stars of debt in this damage
Friday I got a bag of [ __ ] stars I'm
gonna hail in like six of them before
the first show and
beep-beep-beep deep for the second show
you understand I suggest you do the same
[ __ ] I suggest you do the same
[ __ ]
I like the Bombardier come in pilot to
Bombardier in and I said people we rap
who won now see that's a crowd were
bolting and I think I'm making a
landlord GU honey Jean the old woman boy
in Guam enthroned our logo on it and buy
yourself a missile happy he worked in a
while up here me boy I mean we put the
right to marry cornucopia somali i mean
i mean put the oil pull not being an
intro on our salad I don't give a [ __ ]
that's what I just said I really don't
that's the way I've been on all my
[ __ ] life I really duck we got to
worry about what I'm gonna say no to you
who gives a [ __ ] get dressed run some
water on your face wash your little dick
helmet and get the [ __ ] out there and
get your [ __ ] dream by the [ __ ]
boss
you're gonna sit there
why some fat [ __ ] smoke reefer what's a
man what you mean
did you like together
it's a night together you understand
you've not your hand up like this but it
was you need this in your life
that one [ __ ] hair sticking up where
you'll electrocute us and [ __ ]
laughs you wanna take the podcast will
good this week that great good
gotta be honest with yourself
sometimes it will do hi we drop the
[ __ ] ball buddy now we switch runner
that's all that matters least were
swinging for consistent and that's the
most important thing I learned a big
lesson that same [ __ ] every day the same
wave is a shadow your [ __ ] either
6000 burger every day at the same time
and we should do something and make a
move am L here a mil there the [ __ ]
what the but we'll get that type
adjutant rappin you live in your life
people harvest your fears in Tempe
Arizona I think my main man Joe Rogan's
in Boston and I'm here get the [ __ ]
Sun I don't know where the [ __ ]
something is you know that we simply
[ __ ] bullets jumping up and down
which the marshal devil-worshipping
will write some jokes but using
kettlebells to have the Sun get a little
vitamin D a couple [ __ ] Turkish get
up some swings maybe some cleans do a
protein shake take a little [ __ ]
yeah
[ __ ] news hour a half [ __ ] nap get
up and smoke some dope and go down and
kill these [ __ ] dog does that
sit at the end of the week that's all
you got you got I got the state that nut
Mel who gives a [ __ ] my movies TV I got
the [ __ ] stage [ __ ] that's where you
[ __ ] get up there throw your [ __ ]
that's natural my [ __ ] balls comes
from so they went in the smoke under the
ball you
I go back the work would have got me I
got a smokin on the boat we want to sit
sit if not I got it you're heavier and
my [ __ ] fields under stop the ball
with you without you II your mother
young
look at that
I'm telling you I'm booting from the
[ __ ] 30-yard line today
let's do one more I know that respect
this Friday I mean I see you tomorrow
like your podcast Sunday night
oh [ __ ] just like you see that move oh
[ __ ] come an action like the big black
Kahuna I wish you would have just a
little sooner now rich like silver spoon
up Oh little timberland Magoo from back
there the old there we do you're gonna
have a good week and I hope be safe be
with your family
whatever you need your pipe sucked if
you're a woman somebody hope you like
give little [ __ ] little clear of
lemon make you giggle you know you know
man you're nobody today I'm just talking
to you [ __ ] from the heartland
you know this could be easy
what is to be on something
what do you think will [ __ ] close
hold on you [ __ ] like you look
Joey nobody
that's it
but trying to say
nothing I'm selling you just got a pipe
maybe got a notebook write what you want
how you gonna get down
that's it you can become a millionaire
you want to send me a [ __ ] dollar or
a t-shirt or whatever even that man
Mona Lisa Mona Lisa
men have named you as I start singing a
shell tones it's open that means that
the THC has won the battle is that you
no time
what can I tell you I don't do this for
this ain't a museum you'll see me
showing you buds look at this giant with
a filter I got a little hat on there's
nothing to them I'm ugly seven days a
week but I got a big dick a lot of
personality a lot of heart understand me
that's what I give you
we got to go
I got [ __ ] to do to be able to see
maybe we'll chitchat later maybe we
won't to have a great day you know I
love you [ __ ] with all my heart
without you I'll ever bats stay black
stick up for yourself
[ __ ] him watch men on fire
/ now I have a great [ __ ] we can't
see you guys Sunday night for the
podcast